هذه الصور المباشره التي ننقلها لكم هذه
الصور لعمليات الانقاذ التي ما زالت
مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه حيث الجرافات تحاول
ازاحه الحطام والركام وهناك تركيز طبعا
وفق البيانات والمعطيات للاهالي
والمواطنين حول بنايه ما في اي منطقه بان
هناك قد يكون تحتها اشخاص على امل ان يكون
منهم ناجون هذا اولا بالنسبه للاولويات
ايضا يتم التركيز على اكثر البلدات
والمناطق تضررا مثلا اذا تحدثنا عن الشمال
السوري جنديرس في عفرين في حلب هي من اكثر
المناطق تضررا بالتالي التركيز عليها بشكل
كبير جدا اما اذا تحدثنا عن بلده
الاصلاحيه في غازي عنتاب في تركيا فهي من
اكثر المناطق تضررا بالتالي هي منطقه
منكوبه بالكامل فهذه هي الصور التي لم
تهدا طبعا عمليات الانقاذ لم تهدا وحتى
المتطوعين ومن وصل لمحاوله المساعده
وتقديم المساعده بابسط الامكانيات وحتى
الاليات التي تم الاستعانه بها من قبل
المساعدات مثلا نائب رئيس التركي قال امس
امس بانه اكثر من مئه الف شخص يشاركون في
الانقاذ حتى هذه اللحظه